from an exceedingly evil Ursula to
horrifying references from the original
tragic fairy tale there are a stack of
gruesome changes and Sinister Secrets
hidden in Disney's live-action remake of
The Little Mermaid let's kick things off
with Ursula one of Disney's most iconic
villains and the new movie really amps
up what a Despicable Baddie she truly is
so when we first meet her this time
she's complaining about wasting away in
Exile while spearing some shrimp with
their fingernail and chomping it down as
a snack this addition is also a Grizzly
little bit of foreshadowing for her own
death at the end when she gets stuck
with the pointy end of a ship's mast and
for the Remake Ursula's lure has
acquired some even scarier creatures
compared to the animated version gone
are the polyps which contain The Souls
of merfolk that came back to life after
Ursula died and these have been replaced
by nightmarish single-eyed lovecraftian
monsters that remind me of the monster
in the doctor strange sequel these new
creatures grab aerial by the neck at one
point in a deep cut reference to the
original fairy tale where one of the
polyps outside the sea Witch's House
strangled a Little Mermaid to death as
for why the filmmakers cut the original
movie's polyps director Rob Marshall
thought that seeing them turn back into
people was something that could only
work in animation and that Triton
turning into a polyp would be too
comical for a live-action movie in the
new movie the floor in Ursula's cave is
littered with skulls and even the entire
skeleton of a mer person proving that
the fate of those who crossed Ursula is
now even worse than those Poor
Unfortunate Souls in the animation this
new look layer is also a nod to the
original fairy tale where the sea
Witch's House was located in the middle
of a forest of serpent-like half animal
half plant polyps with long arms that
trapped the skeletons of dead humans and
animals which had sunk to the Bottom of
the Sea in fact it's implied later on
when Flotsam and Jetsam electrocute King
Triton draining him of life that that's
how Ursula kills her victims by the way
the skeleton of the whale-like creature
that forms Ursula's new lure is based on
unused concept art from the animated
movie live action Ursula's
transformation into a giant kaiju-like
monster was very impressive although her
death and the Remake is a little less
grisly than the animation with the
camera cutting away when the ship's
Spike pierces the giant villain and also
her not getting electrocuted by
lightning this time in the new movie
though Ursula does become even more
monstrous with gruesome gills added to
her cheeks and huge deadened eyes
possibly a hat tip to her evil red eyes
in this scene in the animated movie when
Disney first adapted Hans Christian
Anderson's fairy tale for their animated
classic they softened many of the darker
edges of the original story however many
of these are back in various forms in
the new film so during Ariel's
transformation listen very carefully and
you'll hear tearing sounds as her tail
rips and splits into 2. in Anderson's
original story the sea witch Tells A
Little Mermaid that when the potion
transforms her Finn into human legs she
will feel great pain as if a sword were
passing through her body and later on
when Scuttle asked Sebastian whether
Ariel has killed the Prince yet it's a
sneaky Sinister reference to how in the
fairy tale when The Little Mermaid
failed to gain the prince's true love
her mermaid sisters struck a deal with
the sea witch that if she killed the
Prince with a dagger and put his blood
on her feet she would be able to turn
back into a mermaid in Anderson's story
if the prince ended up marrying another
woman the little mermaid's fate would be
to die the next morning and become the
foam that floats on the crest of the
ocean waves so when the movie's opening
scene is of giant foaming waves it's no
coincidence at the start there's also a
quote from Anderson's fairy tale but a
mermaid has no tears and therefore she
suffers so much more a moment which pays
off at the very end when in her human
form Ariel sheds her teeth and she says
goodbye to her father likewise the fairy
tale also ends with the little mermaid's
tears as she refuses to kill the prince
and so gains an eternal soul
a small but significant and bloody
change in the live action is how Ariel
agrees to her deal with Ursula by
signing It in Blood after plucking a
scale from her own tail rather than
signing her name as she did in the
animated movie this side steps are
commonly cited plot hole from the
animation that Ariel could have easily
explained to Eric why she was mute by
writing down how she'd lost her voice
and that she was the one who saved him
in tune with many of Disney's
live-action remakes some of the wackier
more slapstick elements in the animation
have been removed from this version an
unfortunate casualty is French Chef
Louis notorious for his obsessive and
ridiculously Ott efforts to catch and
cook the little crab Sebastian and he's
been chopped out of the new film meaning
of course that the song Le poisson is
also missing
there is however a nod to that sequence
in both the Castle's fishy tiles and
when Sebastian says he could have been
fricassade try trying to reach Ariel in
the animated movie one of the thingama
Bobs that Ariel found in the sunken ship
was a tobacco pipe that was amusingly
named and described by Scuttle a bandit
bulbish narf flat oh however since 2007
Disney has banned the depiction of any
smoking products in any of its movies
rated PG-13 or less so all of the
amusing animated scenes featuring The
snarf blat have been completely banished
from the Remake the live-action movie
reveals that Ursula is actually Triton's
sister making her dastardly scheme
against Ariel her own niece feel even
worse and more malevolent the film also
explains that Ariel's mother was killed
by humans however what was left out but
explained in the movie's novelization
visit Ursula's actions were also
responsible for that death apparently 15
years earlier the sea witch
shape-shifted into the form of Triton's
wife the sea Queen and then attacked a
human ship but was caught and when
Ariel's mother decided to help us in our
Escape she ended up dying this was the
event that led Triton to banish his
Wicked Sister and it also appears that
Eric's birth family was killed during
Ursula's attack and she's therefore the
reason why he was Shipwrecked and
orphaned and ended up being adopted
similar to The Lion King the live-action
Little Mermaid strives for a
photorealistic world in its depiction of
Life Under the Sea although this is a
technically impressive feat it does mean
a good deal of the expressive emotions
conveyed by the animated animals isn't
translated into live action of all the
characters flounder suffered the most
from this and the internet completely
freaked out when they saw him for the
first time as visually he simply doesn't
have the fun and vibrancy of his cartoon
counterpart by the way I thought it was
a little shocking how Scuttle quite
casually swooped into the water in front
of Ariel and Flounder to snack on some
fish obviously gannets and other birds
do eat fish in real life but it was a
little weird how Ariel wasn't shocked at
the horror this you okay flounder sure
you gotta show him who's in charge
it's just Scuttle while being clearly
perturbed later on at seeing pictures of
fish on hooks in the human world
Sebastian's New Look is based on the
Cuban land crab and he has a much larger
front right claw than his left one
another change made to make the crab as
realistic as possible because he has
larger eyes than his fish friends though
he still has a little more ability to
emote though it can't quite compare to
the animation in this regard and while
the live-action version of under the sea
is visually spectacular indeed it looks
just gorgeous and it's very impressive
reminding me of some of Busby Berkeley's
choreography it doesn't quite hit the
comedic notes of the original song as it
strives to be more photo real there's
definitely a lot of interesting changes
in the remake and I'd love to hear what
you thought of them I especially enjoyed
Hallie Bailey and Melissa McCarthy's
performances and if you enjoyed this
video do leave a thumbs up and subscribe
to get more videos like this thanks for
enjoying the Little Mermaid with me and
hope you have a marvelous movie loving
week yippie kai movie lovers
foreign